perdu un pari de paris iii par emile
paris elle des derniers sont dans la
merde à cause de leurs enfants ils
varient n'importe quoi qu'il faut bien
comprendre le pari sportif c'est qu'en
fait le système
il est construit contre toi paris
sportifs gagnent 800 euros en paris
audio gagner beaucoup d'argent sans
effort c'est la proposition de nombreux
sites de paris sportifs grosse cote gros
gain et respect sont partout que ce soit
sur l'espace public dans les gars même
sur youtube les les pubs l'ad'abord
vidéo pendant les vidéos les plumes à la
télévision on peut même parler des
sentiments on a une pub pour betclic
on en nous disant que nos matches ils
sont beaucoup plus intense avec betclic
ces publicités elle vise un public bien
particulier des jeunes urbains issus de
quartiers populaires pour ça elles
reprennent leurs codes mais aussi de
nombreux clichés
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux le hashtag nobel
odette dénonce l'hyper visibilité de ces
sites de paris sportifs ou là un peu
comme comme à chaque match la petite
meute chiffres d'avant match lé bus une
cote pour pas oublier de parier sur le
match
beaucoup d'internautes et de supporters
mettent aussi en garde contre les
risques d'addiction avant de parier je
trouve que matisse était beaucoup plus
sympa non maintenant je suis constamment
la surveiller mon pari il faut qu'ils
passent faut qu'ils passent même si six
la mise et maps et buteur et que c'est
benzema qui ma limite je vais mais je
vais être déçu alors que devrait
j'essaye de nous faire passer un message
à travers eux mêmes tout simplement
jérémy à 19 ans il a commencé à les
paris sportifs à 14 ans au début il se
rendait en bureaux de tabac mais
l'arrivée des applications lui a
facilité la tâche et de toute mon
enfance jusqu'à ma majorité j'ai dû en
faire facilement une cinquantaine jeu
jeanne on m'a demandé mon âge jamais on
m'a mis en garde
là avec les applications c'est c'est
trop simple parce que même la carte
bancaire elle est déjà enregistré 2 dans
on met le temps on met le cvc de l'a4
est en apparence si je prends mon
téléphone je peux faire un dépôt de 10
euros en deux secondes
combien d'argent est ce que tu penses
avoir dépensé depuis tu fais des paris
sportifs moi j'ai pas fait de ce pas
fait de compte avec précision parce que
ça peut être me donner mal au ventre
mais deux têtes on va dire entre 2005
3000 euros si on compte les paris gagné
que j'avais investi on doit autour des
4000 4005 facilement en termes de gain
je dois être sûr en grand maximum et 800
euros selon l'autorité nationale d
70% des parieurs en ligne ou moins de 35
ans et le foot représente 64% des mines
comme de l'argent facile or c'est
vraiment pas le sait vraiment tout le
contraire ce cas après fonctionnement
les pronostiqueurs ils ont tendance à
essayer de ramener les jeunes on
comprend vraiment des groupes combinés
qui passent mais le jour où ils perdent
on l'est on les voit pas en fait on les
voit pas mettre leur leur fuite en
disant j'ai gagné autant parce qu'ils
ont perdu
là on a forcément tous des prélèvements
qui doivent passer tous les mois sur mon
compte bancaire donc des fois quand on
est vraiment dans dans une addiction
forte pardon on va forcément misé
l'argent qui était prévu pour payer
autre chose en se disant on va gagner ça
sera payée sauf que là on perd et c'est
pas payé donc il ya des prélèvements
crise et ensuite il faut savoir
expliquer ça la famille c'est ma mère
qui m'a aidé et puis on a pris rendez
vous à la jeep pologne et puis puis
depuis ce temps je sais ce qu'il est par
le dip tôt je parie encore la différence
aujourd'hui c'est que j'utilise deux
applications comme betclic ou je faisais
tout mais paris c'est j'aurais dû
beaucoup vous dire on est un grand
maximum 100 euros par mois si je craque
et derrière je suis sûr au mada sport
donc c'est la même chose que tous les
autres sauf que c'est gratuit pour moi
je suis encore à dicton mais juste en
train de travailler là dessus et ça
viendra pas par le temps